we're covering variants and in in little
brackets standard deviation today
because standard deviation is really
just variance you take the square root
we'll talk about that in a second I want
to call your minds back to what we had a
look at yesterday it was this guy this
notation does anyone remember what the
age stands for
expected value thank you very much what
we did was we we took you on the journey
from discrete random variables what the
expected value look like for that and
then we said yeah but wearing continuous
random variable land so we don't have
the Sigma notation which adds up a bunch
of discrete things we have an integral
right you do it over your entire domain
wherever your probability density
function is defined and then if you've
got your notes there you're welcome to
call on that but I wonder if anyone
remembers what's the thing we actually
integrate in oracle x times the
probability density function fantastic
and the whole idea here is you're like I
want to know the score and then I want
to know the probability of that score
and that's the score that's the
probability the score add them all up
off you go
okay by the way we know if we didn't
include that X if we just did the
integral from the side to the end of the
function we know what the answer would
be right it would be it would be 1 and
you should know rustling because you
actually found one because that's all
the probabilities without thinking about
what scores there correspond to it ok so
so far so good now what we're gonna do
is we're gonna extend from that idea
into this idea of variance and it's been
a while since we had a look at this so
the variance notation looks like this
and I should point out we're actually
going to like the variance depends on
the expected value and so that's why I
wanted to remind you of that but there's
this other notation for expected value
you know it's this just like with
derivatives you like ah why do we have
so many same ways to describe the
derivative dy/dx f - x2 all that right
it's because we use them in multiple
contexts and expected values like that
right I'm sure mer expected value is
equivalent to working out the mean of a
distribution remember that right so
we're kind of like running out of
English letters because we want this to
be called the mean we use the Greek
letter
I'm the Greek letter that corresponds to
M is mu M you write and maybe you're
familiar with that from like like
micrograms uses this same symbol okay so
um mu for mean and we're going to use
that in a second okay now what is
variance when you hear the word variants
like what did that sound like certain
again
sounds like variable it sounds like
change right the idea
yeah variation all of these are the same
idea it's trying to measure like how
spread out is my daughter how much does
it vary from the mean does that make
sense like I can work out the mean
height of our class the expected value
if I picks on at random but I want to
know okay do you have like a big spread
like are there lots of really tall
people and what's really short people or
is everyone very close together that
makes sense so here's the way that we
work it out it's another integral right
it's again over the entire interval
because you you do need every single
value that's in there and then what you
do is you're calculating not the score
times its probability you're trying to
work out like something to do with how
the scores vary from the mean so this is
the way that we do it I'm going to write
it down and then we're gonna unpack it
okay it's X take away mu that's just our
other notation for expected value for
mean we square that guy and then we
multiply by f of X okay so there's a lot
there let's try and unpack what on earth
this means okay for starters and don't
drown in alphabet soup okay I'm gonna
tell you exactly what everything means
and why it's there
okay so let's look at look at this guy
first X take away mu why are we doing
this you're looking at some x value
right some school and then saying well
what's the difference between that score
and your average yeah so again sorry
that I keep coming back to so I just
want something in your mind right say
we're talking about the height of the
class and just say for the sake of
argument that 178 centimeters is the
average height I actually think it's
pretty close to that but whatever okay
if I do your height takeaway the average
height what I'm finding is the
difference between you
the mean does that make sense right so
you might be let's say you were 170
centimeters tall right so you get 170
take away 178 said to be
oh I'm negative 8 that's how far below I
am the mean or if you're taller you're
gonna be above the mean you get the idea
so what this guy tells you and you
really need to write this down so you're
not just looking at all these symbols
right this is the difference from the
mean and what we do is we find the
difference from the mean for every
single score that's why it's an integral
all the way through from A to B so we do
this every single time okay but the
whole idea is like can you picture let's
say we have our our meaning 178 right
suppose we had one half the class was
just super super tall and then the other
half the class was super short okay now
if I did this calculation for everyone
I'll come to your question in a second
can you see if like say I had everyone
who is 8 centimeters shorter than the
mean and ever and who is 8 centimeters
taller than the mean if I added up all
of these differences for every person
that was shorter there'd be a person who
is taller and then another one is
shorter than others taller when you add
them all up what would happen your
negative eights and your eights would
just cancel right negative 8 a cancel
negative 5 5 cancel right now that's
that's not what we want right that would
tell me that's like oh one of the
differences zero we don't want that we
actually have a class that's very varied
this should not turn out to zero if we
have this variance does that make sense
so that's why that's why we square in
here right because then what this does
is it says are the negative 8 turns into
64 the 8 positive 8 also turns into 64
so when you start adding all these
things up you're like ah ah you're all
different from the mean okay so the idea
here is that we are taking magnitude and
the size of the difference magnitudes
just the fancy word right how big is the
difference not which way is it magnitude
not direction to connect this to another
idea we looked at in the last couple of
weeks this is like saying hey I'm more
interested in speed than velocity just
don't know how fast you're going right
this is about saying how
big is the difference I don't care if
you're shorter or if you're taller I
just want to know how far are you from
the mean does this make sense okay and
then we're still multiplying by
probabilities and then adding them all
up okay there are a couple of questions
here before did your question get
answered or not yet yeah honey is yeah I
mean what we want is the difference
without the negative business in it okay
yeah no your question yes essentially
yes okay now I will point out because
it's in the heading right variance has
this squaring thing in it
okay variants has this squaring thing in
it so there's a piece of notation we use
to sort of convey that which is that you
often see this which is a lowercase
Sigma you're like it doesn't look
anything like the uppercase C remember
whatever its Sigma squared right which
is to indicate this this sort of
squaring process that happens here okay
whereas Sigma just by itself that's
standard deviation in fact on your
calculator back when we had to work out
standard deviation um you might remember
I mean it's low resolution so it's hard
to actually see but the Sigma indicates
standard deviation Sigma squared is
variance and that is in fact exactly how
you calculate it if you knew standard
deviation and you wanted variance you
just square it or you can really the
other way is actually more common you
find out this if you want standard
deviation you take the square root does
that make sense
I'll give an example that in a minute
okay now this result here okay this
integral is good because once we like
put in the a and the B and whatever this
is like whatever value we calculate it
to be and whatever function we happen to
be working with you once you put all
that stuff in you know how you like are
now calculus brain just kind of takes
over and I don't really worry about
whether it's a probability or not I'm
just dealing with integrating up and
something you valued okay this is one
teeny little problem okay this result
here this integral it ends up being
really hard a lot of the time okay
in fact in practical terms the only time
you can really use this result is when
you have and you want
drop this down on the side so you've got
like a visual marker for yourself
generally speaking the only time we use
this way to find the variance is when
you have a distribution that looks like
this do you remember the name of this if
you had a probability density function
and it had the same value all the way if
this was f of X what do we call this yes
we call this a uniform probability
distribution because all the
probabilities are the same now these
functions right they're really easy like
they're just it equals a number like I
don't know 1 over 20 I think was one of
the examples that we had right so this
is so simple you can use this technique
it works mine and I will give you an
example of that but usually we don't
have something nice and neat we don't
usually have a uniform distribution so
we kind of want an easier way okay now
as a consequence right this underneath
we had this other way of calculating
variance I'm not going to prove at this
lesson because it would literally take
the entire lesson to prove it I'm gonna
make a video that for that later on it
you can look at it actually and leisure
this actual proof is not something you
really need to know but you do need to
know there's there's two ways to do it
so I'm going to show you what those two
ways are now there's wave number one
here comes the second way I'm gonna make
sure I get right to it there's a lot to
it we're still gonna square variance
still has this squaring business in it
because we're still trying to get
positives out of it you still multiply
by your functions so that's the
probability okay but this thing here
isn't variance on its own you have to
subtract your expected value squared mmm
for me the way I remember this is see
how there's an X minus mu squared here
it's kind of very similar it's not
identical this actually there's like 15
lines of working in between here so it's
not simple or trivial at all but you do
eventually get to here and what's great
about this is that unlike the other
result this guy here this is so much
easier to work with okay even if you
have like some not some nice simple
thing if you got some we
thing in here it still ends up being
relatively straightforward